Heather is in Little Rock Arkansas hi
Heather how are you I'm great Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
okay my husband and I have been married
for almost six years now we've been
together for six years going on seven
and he came into the relationship with a
mortgage with his ex fiance and through
a turn of events they she now lives in
that house and he signed a quitclaim
deed to get off of the legal in well he
still it it's still on his credit it's
still he's still liable for the morning
yes he's still liable for the mortgage
and so we're trying we just recently
started implementing your plan and
that's one of the hurdles that we have
this is on his you know on his part of
the credit so we're wondering how we can
get how he can get offers so he never he
bought a house with a fiancee he was
they were never even married
no they were not and then he quit claims
it to her yes he gave up the asset and
kept the liability dumb all right
because he lost all leverage so there's
no agreement here anywhere other than he
just tossed her the keys and walked away
yeah and stayed on the mortgage all
right so do you know anything about the
mortgage I know that it through Chase
Bank I think do you know the loan you
know the interest rate I do not know the
interest rate he probably there's
probably still fifty to sixty thousand
dollars left on it okay but I don't know
the interest rate or anything like that
okay and she's obviously just going to
camp there for ever
yes and she's still he's not she's
paying the mortgage we're not you just
have what's called a contingent
liability meaning that if she doesn't
pay it you're going to get stuck with
the bad credit and a potential
foreclosure yeah so all right and what
Cheryl's household income right now it's
just 21,000 I'm about to go back to work
and we I was taking care of helping take
care of what will your household income
be I would say probably thirty or
thirty-five thousand so you make ten
thousand bucks at all well it's just
part-time
I'm I don't I'll be making so much dad
dad have you got we're not counting this
fiance oh my goodness there's probably I
don't haven't figured it up exactly but
it's probably ninety thousand and that
the majority of that student loans yeah
and that's not making any money as a
result of that education Wow okay I
would worry about that dead before I
worry about this mortgage if you can get
out of when you're out of debt and the
only thing left standing is that
mortgage and she still hasn't paid it
off a refinance that at that point I
might offer to pay her refinance cost in
order to get her to refinance it into
her own name and maybe at a better
interest rate or something this is the
Dave Ramsey show